Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan. And today, we
are going to take a look at KWasm.
KWasm is a project that wants to make
it easier for you to run WebAssembly workloads
on your Kubernetes
clusters.
So guidance for today's session, I am joined
by Christophe and Sven from Liquid Reply who
are also working on the KWasm project.
Hi there. How are both doing?
Hello.
Yeah.
Thank you for for having us. Super excited
to be here.
Awesome. Well, let's start with a bit of
a a round of introductions. Why don't you
just tell me more about each of you?
Yeah. Sure.
So I'm going to start. My name is
Christopher. I'm living in,
yeah, sunny Hannover in in Germany.
I'm a father of two beautiful daughters, and
I'm doing Golang and Kubernetes for a living.
I'm a managing director at Liquid Reply
consultancy,
which is, like, focusing on Kubernetes,
container orchestrators,
and, yeah, cloud native technology.
So we try to bring this
cloud native and cloud agnostic mindset
to our customers,
And customers usually approach us to build up
their Kubernetes clusters,
to migrate workloads from on prem to the
cloud,
to optimize their clusters, make them secure,
find performance bottlenecks,
write custom controllers, custom software on top of
Kubernetes.
And,
yeah, all of a sudden, we found also
found out that
WebAssembly is also a nice target that can
be run-in Kubernetes and
became a research topic of of Liquid Reply.
This is what we talk about today. Sven?
Yeah. Hi. I'm Sven Van Nijk, lead developer
at Liquid Reply.
And,
yeah, unfortunately, here we are allowed to dedicate
some time for open source projects.
And therefore, I turned the
experimental work with Rawkode into an open source
project.
And, yeah, that's why we are here to
show you how easy it is to get
started with WebAssembly and Kubernetes.
Awesome. No. You're say something there, Christophe. Off
on you go.
How how easy it became, actually, because it
was quite a quite a journey until became
easy.
Oh, yeah. Why don't we take a couple
of minutes? Like,
before KWasm,
what what what was the process of running,
and was it possible to run a WebAssembly
workload on a Kubernetes cluster? Why don't you
start with that?
Yeah. So, basically,
it's
KWasm is not a runtime. It's not a
Kubernetes distribution. It's just an installer. So we
take the awesome work of the people out
there who have created integrations
for WebAssembly on Kubernetes
and install them on the cluster. So, yes,
before it was possible to install it on
your cluster,
but
you always need to know what you're doing.
So in this round, that's not a problem
at all. But when you think of an
Blazor developer
who has is is
using his framework, it just outputs and represent
the file. And now you're asking yourself, how
can I run this?
So
for this audience, we created this
installer
to just have a Kubernetes cluster,
put an operator on it, label your notes,
and you can theoretically start your represent applications.
So what this means, we will see in
a few minutes.
But
how it was before,
Short spoiler. We will see in a few
minutes after when we're doing this on our
own cluster.
Yeah. So let me fill the audience on
on our mission and our plan for today.
So when we talked about doing this,
you've already said, right, it's easy. Like this
was hard. It's very easy. And that you've
done all this amazing tooling. And then we're
gonna see the easy mode, which is to
get KWasm to get a kind cluster ready
for web assembly workloads.
And you promised me, you've not promised, but
I'm gonna tell everyone you promised me. But
that's gonna take thirty seconds. Right? I'm sure
it'll take maybe a little bit. Wow.
No pressure. Absolutely no pressure whatsoever.
Just for the audience, I I said under
five minutes. Now it's thirty seconds.
I've got faith in you. So
but of course, I mean, I I
spun up a bare metal cluster because that's
every time I need to do something like
Kubernetes, my my go to is bare metal.
And I think this will give us a
really viable
insights into what we actually need to do
to prep a Kubernetes cluster for on a
web assembly workloads and user. Hopefully,
we're gonna be successful. Let's positive mindset here.
We're we're gonna get this bare metal cluster
running a web assembly workload
or, you know,
no. There's no failure. I'm not even gonna
accept what we're gonna do. So
I'm gonna I mean, there's a there's a
very high chance that it that it's going
to work. Right? I mean, we tried it
with a lot of clusters from a lot
of cloud providers. So depending on your specific
configuration, I guess, like, if if there's anything
arcane going on in the machines, it should
work as well.
Yeah. It's
a traditional Ubuntu machine, cube admin cluster, run-in
container d.
Hopefully, what most people are doing on the
bare metal environment and not going to off
the beaten track because keep admin works well,
continue the works well and web assembly is
the same prospect. We're gonna bridge all that
as mission together and I'm excited for that.
Cool. Let me share my screen. So
there we go. We
have
a cane control plane, a cane cluster,
just a standard done five minutes ago with
kind
create cluster command.
Nothing fancy here. Yeah. Russell, I was gonna
mention the hoodie and I don't want to
because I
don't know how to pronounce that if it's
or I or Ori. Maybe maybe Christophe will
tell us.
I personally pronounce it ori. Ori. Ori.
Actually, I have I have no clue. I
I should have followed a closer the
the talk from from Chris Noble from the.
So she was talking about ori and what
it's like
about.
Definitely look into it. It's very it's very,
very interesting and exciting project. Can we run
WebAssembly workloads on it yet?
Not yet. Yeah.
Alright. And that sounds like a coming soon
segue. So Exactly.
Alright. So I have my can cluster
super vanilla. What I'm going to do is
pull up
KWasm
here.
So you've already kinda covered us, but let's
just touch it again so we kinda clarify
it for the audience. KWasm is not a
runtime. So maybe you can give us a
TLDR and what we're about to do to
our kind cluster.
So, basically,
there are different kinds of runtime
at the moment available. One is the WASM
edge runtime, which is basically used by Docker
for this is powering the Docker WASM integration.
And there is also the
spin based containers.
At the moment, there is a WASM node
pool
preview on
Azure.
So you could already
use them on
Azure with the node pool preview.
And we thought,
why not
make it available to the other cloud and
even for local development? So
that's basically
the idea
using this existing run times and installing this
on your cluster.
On the left hand side, you have the
quick start, and that would be everything you
need to get started with
your current cluster.
Okay. So looking at this, KWasm can prepare
my cluster to run WASM edge applications, WASM
time applications, even for me on spend applications,
which is very exciting for me. I do
a lot with spend, and I'm excited to
see
that in my Kubernetes cluster.
So
it looks like the installation is Helm based.
Exactly. So we thought
it is a common way to distribute
some YAML, and that's why we just go
with Helm.
Alright. I'm just going to very quickly run
through this. I am gonna modify your helm
command because
I don't know. I just feel very uncomfortable
when I run helm install. I always have
to do upgrade dash dash install. Just I
click the item put of it just makes
me happy.
So we're gonna have a home release. It's
gonna be called KWasm operator and say the
KWasm namespace
and we have a chart KWasm KWasm operator.
For anyone coming from Kubernetes, this is all
stuff that they're very happy and comfortable with.
So no surprises.
I do want to do before we move
on to annotate in any nodes
is just look at what we have inside
of our cluster. I'm assuming it's just gonna
be a single pod running your KWasm controller.
Yeah.
It's just an operator using the operator SDK.
It's written in Go.
So if you're familiar with that, it's just
all the defaults you could use.
Alright.
Now it doesn't do anything by default, I'm
assuming, based on the fact that the next
instruction is to annotate
a node or all nodes in our cluster
with KWasm.s
h.
Operator,
so it should not do anything without you
having to told it so. So there are
also values in the values file of the
Helm charts, so
you could do it in one step. But
to be safe,
just install the
Oh, we lost them.
Lost everybody.
Sorry. I have no idea what happened there,
but I think it was an error on
EK.
Me neither. So
Hopefully, Christophe comes back to join us.
Yeah. Alright. Let's let's we'll carry on for
now. Hopefully, he makes it back. I think
it was just a temporary blip and it
seems to have resolved itself now.
So we were yep. There we go. Welcome
back, Christophe. I don't know what happened. I
think it's my software. I don't think it's
you. Because I got an error message saying
ECAM
error,
but it looks like we're okay now. So
Alright.
Sweet. Yeah. So we're about to we've we've
already annotated our note. I'm assuming now you've
installed some sort of eBPF rootkit onto my
machine. You have root access, and you're remaining
on my bank details of Bitcoin. Is that
correct?
To to to be precise,
yes. This just
installing something from a random helm in the
Internet, starting in
super privileged container, which can do something on
your notes is is
as good as doing a curl and piping
as with sudo and bash. So it's
the the same safe situation you see on
all the websites.
So in in fact, we cannot we cannot
promise you what's happening in any any case.
So,
I mean, my understanding, and I'm often wrong,
so feel free to correct me. Right? Is
that we haven't really done anything to this
cluster except you have
provisioned
some
wasm run times
onto the underlying host.
So when you see the difference to see
pods before, there is now a completed job.
Yep. So yep. Exactly.
And this job was just
do executing a script,
which so the container is running as root.
In the script, you have some NS enter.
You exit your container. You just walk out
there,
place your binaries in the specific folders of
your host system,
and
changing containerd
config and restarting containerd.
So we will see the script afterwards,
but that's basically what happened. And
as I said, it's like typing something from
the Internet into your bash. You can just
do anything.
This is, by the way, also made maybe
to to add on this because usually what
what you do in case you want to
do something on the host of on on
the level of the host of multi mesh
multiple machines, you're using a demo set. So
we we considered using a demo set. But
what we didn't like about demo set that
even after the install process, demo set would
be still be provisioned on the node. So,
therefore, this highly pro privileged container would also
still live on your node. And, therefore, we
basically decided to to start a job one
once a new node is starting and,
yeah, to to
start the job and and and get rid
of it when once it's done. So this
basically was the idea.
Cool.
Yeah. And
now when you look at the website, we
have two example workloads.
So one for spin and one for Watson
Edge. So when you scroll down for Watson
Edge, this is the manifest. You create a
runtime class
for c one because we are using the
c one integration here and then starting a
container and
port with a container. So the
one important thing is the annotation you see
here. The module was an image variant.
That's something special to c one. So c
one usually works like run c as an
OCI runtime.
But if you give this annotation,
it looks into the container
and sees if it's web assembly container or
Linux container.
And if it's a web assembly container, it's
executed with Watson Edge.
This approach makes it possible to start pods
with
Linux containers
and WebAssembly containers.
So your WebAssembly workload is, with C1,
able to run-in,
sidecar integrations
like Linkerd,
like KDA or,
yeah,
DEPR, whatever uses sidecar.
So that's why we are using not the
container d shim here, but the OCI runtime.
We could use the other one as well,
but
this has still a slight advantage over the
other one.
So I wanted to confirm something there because
I think it's something that that's really exciting
for me personally and and hopefully for others.
But using this approach with c run and
the annotations,
we can have
our main application. Right? Say that just happens
to be a go by any rate right
now that has a web server, server traffic
to customers, maybe it's an API, whatever. It
doesn't matter. Right? We can run a web
assembly, server side web assembly workload and the
same pod
and
perform standard sidecar capabilities. Maybe that's log transformations.
Maybe that's metric collection or something like that.
Is that something that is possible now or
something that's possible in the future?
So basically, you can now run pots with
both type of containers when you are running
c one. So that's that's working.
With the log transformation,
that's
slightly different because
you need
to access the logs.
Yeah. So that's my application.
Obviously, it's it's written to to to standard
out, but I could have it multiplex that
and put the standard out to fail as
well. Can I share that fail with the
WASM edge
run time
application?
Let me short think about it. Yes. If
it if it's available in the container, you
should be able to access it.
Isn't that cool? I'm That's
cool. Right? It
is. So I I haven't thought that to
an end because I was always doing it.
It's the other way around. So it wasn't
was always my main application, and I had
supporting things around it. And I have never
used
Rawkode as a sidecar to
support another application, but I like the idea.
Well, yeah, I guess that's that's bidirectional. Right?
I think it either way, I think the
point is completely valid, and that's what I
want people to kinda take away from here
is that, you know, writing services web assembly
is cool and I'm hoping that the audience
is somewhat sold on that rate. And if
you're not go start experimenting with spend, there
was imagine all these other runtime.
But
it's it's this been able to use web
server side by side with containers, which is
really appealing to me personally. And I think
these kind of hybrid architectures are very will
be very big in the future.
But let's not take your word for it.
Right? Should we deploy this? If you scroll
down a bit, you you have the same
safe approach to just
put some YAML into your cluster.
I'm I I I don't I don't mind.
I trust you.
Yeah. And that's running an, I would say,
extremely basic job, which is output we're putting
some information
from
the environments, generating some random numbers, getting the
environment variables.
So
just to show you that the WebAssembly
integration is working.
Maybe we should have started it before integrating
the the WebAssembly runtime so that you can
see it fail. But now you need to
trust me that's a real WASM application and
not something written in Go. Oh, don't you
worry because look at us by the power
of magic. We can go to another cluster
that doesn't have KWasm installed.
So let's see. I need my IP address
because I've accidentally removed it from my dock.
And we slightly hit the thirty seconds you
have promised, but I think that's only because
of connectivity issues.
Yeah. Yeah. It's alright. I'll take the blame
for that one. One hundred percent.
So this is a bare metal Kubernetes cluster
running on Equinix metal. We have a lot
of cores, a lot of RAM,
and we're gonna run the smallest web assembly
workload in New Orleans. But still, it's it's
fun. Right? So Yeah. There you go. For
a Wow.
Nice. Just for the giggles and what was
the gig? Yeah. 64 gig of RAM. So
this is
standard cluster.
Like so.
As running my cluster of workloads and a
post goes up, but we can ignore that
for now. That's just because I use the
same automation just because it's a lot easier
for me. But I'm gonna take your cube
control apply command here.
Now, I guess what's important here, right, is
that we will be able to define the
runtime class and we will be able to
run the same job because these are standard
Kubernetes objects.
But they shouldn't run because it's going to
try and run it with
something
that doesn't know how to interpret it. Is
that correct? Yeah. It's trying to find
c run, and container d should reject that
with, I don't know, something like c run.
And therefore, it should stay in container creating
forever.
Okay. And if
if you describe it, yep, you will see
that it's just saying about I don't have
this runtime.
There we go. Perfect.
Yeah.
So now
We need to get this working. Now
Exactly. This might be a naive question.
Are we just doing a helm install here?
I would say we are looking at the
installer,
and you, who knows your cluster best, says
if it would work or if it not
would work.
What do you think the probability is of
me doing Helm repo add Helm install and
it all just working magically?
Yeah.
30%?
I thought it would have been higher. Alright.
I've do you want me to do this
with Helm or do you want to do
it manually? Let me let me ask that.
Let's have a short look at the installer
script, and then you can say if there
would something be blocking the installer,
and
then we can try it. Okay? Yeah. Of
course. On on the right upper side, you
just end in the repository of the
operator.
But if you go to the organization,
there's also the KWasm node installer repository.
And
I I really love demystifying things, so there
is no magic. So
here's a Dockerfile in
images
installer,
and the Dockerfile is just downloading
compiling and downloading the runtimes
and putting it in a folder called assets.
If you go back and look at the
script, there is an installer script.
And
it just tries to find out if the
it's in an environment
where you just not can't use the standard
procedure, then it's slightly adapted.
But in the end,
you are just copying the binaries in some
spaces,
like in this case, opt KWasm.
You are linking
the
bin files, the lib files,
and
then this
tiny
container d config snippet is executed where you
just add to your container d config, the
c run runtime and the spin runtime, and
I think also the slide runtime, but I
haven't had no.
I don't think so.
And,
yeah, after that, it's just
restarting container d. So
could work on a standard Ubuntu based
container d and Kubernetes.
Yeah. I I don't see anything here
that has me concerned.
No. The only thing It doesn't I don't
know how your script handles it. Is I
don't think there's a container d config by
default.
But other than that, we should be okay.
I'm assuming you just create it anyway if
it doesn't exist. So
let's say that I'm curious.
So I've added the repository. Let's do the
install.
But this was the reason why I was
asking, like, about the operating system beforehand
because I knew that we are restarting with
the system CTL. So
Yeah.
Yeah. This is a standard container to install
system. D is there.
I think Flexi?
I think everything is gonna magically work, and
the stream's gonna be finished, but everyone's gonna
be super happy because it just worked.
Possibly. Yeah.
Alright.
Let's annotate our notes
and see if we get our job.
Almost.
Oh, we got an error. Yeah.
Luckily,
we have an error.
Alright. Let's more interesting. It's it's good. It's
good.
Hey, debug is my favorite pastime. I knew
it was the container deconflict.
So we could fix that. Right? We just
need to create and generate the default container
deconflict.
So we could do that with
is it container the config dump or is
it try control? I can never remember.
Yeah. The community config
dump or default is probably what we Yeah.
And then we want to rate that to
and we'll probably need to make that directory.
Look good to you?
Yeah. Mhmm. Interestingly,
all of the other accumulators distributions always had
a default container.
Yeah. We do app install
container d
because it gives us a default contact. There's
no tweaks.
Yeah. It just works. Because as you know,
I have a show called clustered. And every
time I see a container d config, I
know somebody's fucked with a container d config.
So
get pods.
Hey, it worked.
Yeah.
That's it. Where's the job? Oh, no. It's
on the KWasm interface.
Yeah.
Alright.
So those are all old. So will I
have to clean them up to get a
new one to start?
Yeah. Let's just I need to delete all
approach. That's how I fix things. So Okay.
And now you would need to go to
your notes and there are the
there is the annotation we added, and there
is another annotation
provisioned.
And we just need to remove it. So
we need to edit the note.
I mean, can I just do dash on
this to remove Yeah? Yeah. Or no? Can
maybe you can show the annotation so it's
so that we can see it, actually. Okay.
Yeah. You're right. Sure. Yeah.
So
you want me to remove this?
Yeah.
Exactly.
And then search for keywords. Yeah.
Host. Yeah.
Exactly. The no. Host name is okay.
Yep. That should be it.
Well, there's another node, so let me just
delete.
Oh, we we only need to start it
on one node to see if it's working,
and
then we could do the other one.
Okay.
Re annotate it.
And we should see, hopefully.
Oh, we're not seeing the jobs now. Is
that my fault?
Okay.
Now the real debugging starts.
Yeah.
But the job already existed.
We should probably have picked that up.
Okay. Got it. So it created the job,
but it didn't change and therefore
yeah.
Okay.
So we'll edit our notes again. Search for
KWasm.sh.
Start deleting annotations,
and then I'm gonna annotate one more time.
I
see we definitely need to to make it
more comfortable to
reprovision notes.
Alright. Let's see if we can work out
what's going on with this.
So we still got an error.
Oh, did I
I created you.
Oh, no. Wait. That's on the the worker
node. Right?
Possible.
Yeah. Because I only did it on one
node, but that should be
We should still see the workload scheduled. Right?
Perhaps.
Because it's scheduled on the worker note because
of the scheduler and the tents.
I love how I'm just making everything more
difficult for you with my my setup.
Yeah. Okay.
Interesting. No.
Yeah. Yeah. This is okay. Let me make
sure the audience understands why we're running into
a problem right now. Okay. So KWasm failed
to do the installation because there was no
default container decode. Now I create one on
the control plane.
Removed all the annotations and we run it
again. However, our workload is scheduled on the
worker node where I did not create the
default container deconfiguration.
And that's why currently things are still not
working. However,
we can
split
this and I'll jump onto the worker node
too.
And all we need to do hopefully
is make their
container d and then do container d
config at default and write it to the
expected location.
Now
the config will exist,
but we will need to reprovision the nodes
potentially unless that job is still running.
Maybe we hit the maximum retries.
Yeah. I
think that's definitely the case. So in order
to clean this up, we do need to
delete the job.
We do need to edit the notes.
Find the KWasm dot SH. Yeah. You only
need to remove the
label.
Okay.
Yeah. I just it's just easier, and then
I'll just reapply it. Hopefully,
we have two completely jobs.
Wait. We have a computer. Yeah. So KWasm
worked perfectly. The only problem was the container
deconfiguration
and
my talking too fast and trying to debug
thing. However Yes.
This should mean
we have our WebAssembly workload
scheduled on the worker node.
Feeling confident. This means you can you can
create one of the first bug requests in
in the in the issues of our GitHub
repository. That's nice.
Look at that. And it wasn't that job
completed.
Alright.
Now there was another example here. Right?
Yeah. That Where we could run the spin
application.
Exactly.
So shall we do that too?
Yeah. Sure.
So it's the same approach. We just create
a runtime class.
This time it's called
wasn't time spent.
And then we start,
I would say, very simple
example
from the
container d repository.
Alright. So if we run
now this one's running. Is it fair to
say this is an HTTP application that's gonna
say hello world every time we call it?
Exactly.
Alright.
Now
it's just a deployment. Right? It's just a
deployment.
Okay. So there's no service,
which means No service. We'll have to port
forward
Yeah. The deployment. Okay.
Or just expose it.
And I never remember the syntax for that.
No problem.
Yeah. Forward is fine. Yeah. I've I've no
chance. So
you can do the deploy.
Can you can you port forward to deploy?
Yeah. Yeah. You can. You can do a
deploy slash and then the deployment name.
It it resolves automatically a port and do
that's a port forward to the plot a
port, but it should work. And do you
know the port number? I think it might
be three Eighty. 80. It's just 18. Alright.
So I need to get a second session
on our control plan.
No. Worker. Right?
Worker.
No. Because I'm port forwarding from it.
I'll get there.
Okay.
Yeah. You should go get a 404.
Right?
Yep. So hello.
Have a good one, And
if you are on the worker node. Right?
No. I'm on a control plane, but we're
port forwarding from the control plane. Ah,
okay.
So interestingly,
you could now see what the installer has
placed. So in the
on the worker nodes in your opt folder,
that should
now be a bunch of
binaries and lips.
Yeah. There is a KWasm folder,
and there are the bin and lib folders.
And there you find the container d shims
and the c one binary.
And the c one binary needs the shared
object
from the bottom edge library, which is in
the lip folder,
and they are symlinked into the
according folders of your operating system.
Nice.
This is pretty cool. Like, I now have
a spin application
running inside of my Kubernetes
cluster,
which I'm pretty happy with.
I I I think it would be worth
to to look into the the container
just to show what what's actually inside of
the container that we are
that we just provisioned.
Because, like, a spin application
needs at least your wasn't binary and also
your your spin tunnel, like the configuration for
the spin server. So is it gonna be
possible for me to get a shell? No.
It's No. Pretty like much like a distroless
container, so you don't have a shell in
there, which also means you could do a
debug like with a distroless
container.
I mean, I'm gonna have to read the
help page for that because I have not
used cube cube control debug very much at
all.
So let's copy one of these examples.
Yep.
Well, I think this one yeah. Add the
debug container and exec into it.
Yeah. And for space box.
Okay. So let's get the pod names first
because we'll need that.
And then this is going to do keep
control debug.
I guess my apologies to debug pod name,
which is going to run busy box and
we want to
oh, no. I think it's the other way
around. Right? Mhmm. Yeah. So we want to
debug the
spend.
That sounds right.
And we're gonna copy it to debug then.
There's there's an s missing in the copy
from the port name.
Thank you.
Yeah.
One one thing I
haven't thought about before is that we are
now starting a Linux container in our spin
pod,
which is interpreted by the container d, shim
spin, which can't handle Linux containers. So this
approach is only possible with the c one,
which is not running a server but an
a
job. Okay.
Yeah. Things to improve. I
I guess then then you have to leave
us for now. And but we could at
least look into the Dockerfile so that you
can see how we how we would create
such a Dockerfile because Yeah. Yeah. Sure. So
when you go into the
repository of the days lapse guys of the
container editions Oh, the days lapse one. Okay.
Yeah. We are using the example directly from
the source.
Exactly. Repository?
Yeah. It is. And then
Efficient sources.
Yeah. And then there are images.
There is the spin example,
and there is the Dockerfile. Right.
So
what it
basically does is spinning up a build container,
then doing the
build of the binaries.
So byte code
files.
And
the in the end, it's just using from
scratch
and is copying all the files needed,
which namely is the spin dot toml
and the
two modules that I referenced in that. The
spin dot TOML is in this folder as
well, so we can have a look at
it.
And here you see the two components,
which are just referencing to an,
WASM file that's in the root directory
and a route where you can find it.
This is the hello route we have used.
So there's also the go hello route where
you should get an hello from the go
module.
Nice.
Alright.
Let's recap everything that happened here. So we
had a
vanilla Kubernetes cluster.
We used helm
to add the KWasm repository and install the
KWasm operator.
That's just my cluster and does nothing.
When we annotate a node or multiple nodes
and say that we want to run WebAssembly
workloads on it, the controller will spin up
a privileged pod
and throw all the binaries that we need
onto the host to run our WebAssembly workloads.
This then means that we can add runtime
classes or whatever web assembly runtime we wish
to
run workloads on whether that be WASM edge
or spin or others.
And then we just spin up norm pun
not intended.
Standard Kubernetes deployments with an annotation that says
this is is was it smart compact,
which tells it to find the correct web
assembly workload to run an application.
And by magic of everything that just happened,
we can run our server side WebAssembly applications
inside of a Kubernetes cluster, say by say,
with container workloads even
in the same pod.
Is that right? Yeah. Absolutely.
What a wonderful world we live in.
And if you're, like, living on the cutting
edge and you already have a working spin
application, then it should should already work. I
mean, we we have some some limitations in
terms of, like, for instance, the the Redis
integration is not not yet working.
But apart from this, like, as as as
soon as you're not doing anything fancy, it
should be working.
And if you are doing anything fancy,
so we are also glad to receive issues
and forward them to the right position. So
it should be more and more fancy with
every
release.
Awesome.
Alright. Let's pop back over to
our big faces so we can kinda chalk
this out. And there's one question on the
chat, which is unrelated,
but, you know, I've got opinions. I'm just
gonna answer anyway.
And the bed is asking what is the
most used CNI in production? Is it Celeam
or Calico? I mean, I'm just gonna go
straight and say, if you're not using Celeam,
you're probably making a huge mistake. I'm such
a huge fan of Celeam. Cloud providers are
adopting a support in Celeam.
Do either of you have any opinions on
CNIs before I pop the question away?
I I I tend to use Celeum since
I first encountered in 02/2019 in the KubeCon
NA, and and we're talking to those those
guys. And they're they're beautiful people. I had
the chance to meet them in person and
very, very clever guys. And the product itself
is is really like a blast. And if
you ever, like, had really a network problem
and had the chance of using
Hubble, their their visualization tool for for visualizing
traffic and this kind of stuff.
Like
Oh, ended.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah. I couldn't agree more. I mean, Hubble
is like a superpower. Right? That l four
and l seven visibility into your applications been
able to visualize network policies. This is not
a silly unplug or whatever. I just a
huge fan of silly. I couldn't recommend that
enough. Oh, we've lost them. Oh, we've lost.
They are trying to join again. But of
course, my software is being a pain in
the ass today.
Sorry, folks.
We're we're so close to the financial end
of my software. It's giving you both a
hard time, so sorry about that. But thank
you for coming back.
You're back again. Just just one last thought
about Cilium. I mean, there must be a
reason that it's that it's basically used by
all the major
managed services. So. Yeah.
Yeah. I couldn't agree more. It's fantastic.
Alright. Let's jump back to WebAssembly. We'll we'll
we'll finish up. I wanna say thank you.
You both spent a lot of time with
me today as we've done a couple of
activities.
And it's just been fun talking to you.
It's nice to meet and speak with other
people that are as excited about this hybrid
future world of web assembly and containers at
the site.
Something you mentioned earlier oops. When's it gone?
I'm hoping that doesn't mean that you're gonna
drop again.
So That's good.
You mentioned something earlier that I thought was
interesting. We haven't mentioned on the stream. I
figured maybe we could touch on that. Like,
the goal is for KWasm to not exist.
Is is that correct? And maybe what's gonna
happen in the next three six or nine
months is gonna get us there.
Exactly. So, like, KWasm is there to actually
not exist to to bridge
so, like, to to increase the adoption of
of WebAssembly and to make people
to make it easy for people to try
WebAssembly out and run run on the Kubernetes
cluster. Again, we are a Kubernetescom
company,
so we are actually not really earning money
with WebAssembly.
I mean, maybe some point in in the
future, maybe with with some some consulting in
this
something like this, but definitely not with KWasm.
This is not the not the goal. And,
also, like, we will probably not create any
WebAssembly product or something like this. There are
way more smarter people from from, as I
said, Fermion wasn't cloud and so on.
So
from from our perspective,
we try to contribute something back to the
community,
try to be on on the edge
to to
understand the the developments there.
I'm not not sure. Sven, what do you
think?
He's
thinking nothing or
so he's not frozen at least.
No. But the audience are saying that it's
potentially my bandwidth that is a problem. And
this
I've actually kind of we're streaming in four
k, which was not intentional.
And I think it's causing a little bit
of problems. I'm not sure
if when is is still here, but
you know,
This has been a lot of fun and
keep as some people can go and play
with it today. If you run into issues,
open issues, feel free to contribute. It's all
open source. Get involved.
If you want to discuss WebAssembly Kubernetes in
more details, reach out to Christophe or Sven.
Reach out to Liquid Reply.
Get some assistance. Wonderful people doing a really
cool work in this space.
I just say thank you both for for
oh, he's gone.
Thank you for joining me today and showing
us this project, showing us how to get
started with server side web assembly in the
Kubernetes environment. It's really exciting time, and I
can't wait to do more with it.
Any last words? And I'll let you go
because it seems to be
plentiful, plentiful problems today.
Yeah. Just thank you for having us. And
as I just mentioned, if you have any
kind of questions,
feel free to reach out either on repository
or as well. We are both also available
via
Mastodon and then Twitter. So these are probably
the best
ways to approach us. And, also, like, if
you have any kind of, like, improvements or
things that you would like to see, so
we're happy to integrate this.
Can you hear us now, Sven?
I think he's gone again.
Yeah.
Well, sometimes there's problems in the streams. And
I'm really sorry about that. But thank you
again. I'm glad we could at least still
talk and finish up. So have a wonderful
day. I'll speak to all soon. And thank
you all for watching.
Thank you so much. Bye.